Juliane and derek hough are officially
touring again it's exciting
et spoke with the dancing siblings after
the announcement we wanted to call
something different and something that
you know represents what the show is
gonna be which is beyond anything we've
done before
it's beyond expectation and yeah so it's
exciting this is our third tour we have
had two sold-out tour before and we we
took a year off because you know we had
different projects I did Greece at the
beginning of the year Derrick finished
it off with hairspray and now we're just
kind of ready to go back out there
connect with the fans and and no show
put on a fun live show we love live so
we're gonna be dancing all new
choreography a new stage everything's
everything singing everything they also
revealed that the elements inspired some
of the images in their sets we use the
Earth's elements like with Earth Wind
and Fire and they just kind of like
inspired us just for like a I don't know
just plain getting grounded from a
grounding place I think you know with
beyond it's all about like beyond our
expectations beyond our limits there's
so much that you can do beyond yourself
but at the same time like your core of
who you are is very grounded and and
that's kind of who and what our tour
represents to Derek and Julian's moved
beyond live tour kicks off April 19th in
Akron Ohio
[Music]
you